hi everyone
i'm dan vondrag creative director at
raven one of our goals as developers
is to bring the game world to life
unlike anything you've ever experienced
and the playstation 5 is making that
happen
with the power of the new console we've
been able to significantly enhance the
overall experience
from what you see in the world how it
feels in your hands to what you hear
around you
in black ops cold war you will be
transported to the year 1981
in the middle of one of the most
dangerous times the world has ever known
the height of the cold war the following
is a portion of the first campaign
mission
where you've been given the name of a
high value target linked to the iran
hostage crisis
but in true black ops style nothing is
as it seems
take a look
kasim is out of the picture how long
before we get a rash
the team arrived in turkey a few hours
ago they should be in position shortly
airfield's just up ahead let's go find
this [ __ ]
priority is to ideal raj things go hot
[Music]
check it out
incoming truck left side
mirage might be in the truck
just diced everyone in a truck that's
gotta be a rash
hold fire we need a positive id
that's our man take him out
[Music]
[Music]
yeah him get away
get it
[Music]
we're not done yet
[Music]
do
it's one part of the plan let's go
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed that sneak peek at
the campaign for black ops cold war
there are many more twists and turns
along the way as you begin to unravel
the truth and we can't wait for you to
play it soon
in addition to the story campaign cold
war features the next generation of
multiplayer online combat
and an all new awesome zombies
experience today i have the special
honor to announce on behalf of my
friends at treyarch
that the playstation community doesn't
have to wait to play multiplayer
starting this friday playstation players
will be able to play the multiplayer
alpha exclusively
on playstation 4. and for those of you
that are watching at home on your ps4
you can pre-load the experience starting
tomorrow we can't wait to see you online
friday and through the weekend
enjoy the rest of the show
[Music]
you